good morning Hank it's Tuesday I've been
thinking a lot about my friend Amy
Krauss Rosenthal who Hank has written a
lot of amazing picture books that I'll
be sending you in the coming month she
also wrote a brilliant book encyclopedia
of an ordinary life and as it happens
gave me one of my first big breaks by
the way Hank this video is like Plato's
theory of the soul it comes to you in
three parts part one my big break so way
way back in 2002 I was working at
Booklist magazine and Amy emailed me in
a professional capacity and then I
replied in a mostly professional
capacity while also acknowledging that I
was a massive fan of hers we struck up a
correspondence and then one day she
asked me if I'd ever written anything
about two minutes long that might work
for WBEZ Chicago's public radio station
I didn't have anything to minutes long
but I went home that night wrote a
little essay and then Amy invited me in
to record it and over the next few years
I got to record dozens of essays for
WBEZ and a few for the national NPR show
all things considered and that was
definitely very helpful to me when I was
trying to get my foot in the publishing
door to sell Looking for Alaska but
looking back getting me on the radio
wasn't actually the big break that Amy
gave me the real break was that as both
a writer and a person Amy taught me that
for stories to work readers and writers
must both be generous like when I read
persuasion as a fifteen year old and
declared it to be crap the problem was
not with Jane Austen I wasn't reading
generously I was looking for things to
dislike which meant that I was gonna
find them even when they weren't there
and writing is the same way like I think
what makes Amy's book so special is that
she's not trying to WoW or impress the
reader she's trying to make a gift for
them okay part 2 8 808 so Hank flash
forward a few years to August 8 2008
that was a big day in our lives Hank we
had our first huge nerdfighter gathering
assisted by the fact it happened to
coincide with a Harry Potter convention
that was also the day I first met Rosie
Anna who at the time was a high school
student but is now my production partner
in movie stuff and that evening Amy
hosted an event at the bean in Chicago's
Millennium Park called the beckoning of
lovely it was a really special gathering
and a lot of that day has stuck with me
but I think what stuck with me the most
is being in the dusk at Millennium Park
with hundreds of other people and
singing a song that English soldiers
sang a hundred years ago to the tune of
auld lang syne we're here because we're
here because we're you're not watching
this video to hear me sing point being
the beckoning of lovely was amazing okay
part three eight nine sixteen so it's
now eight years later and Amy has just
finished a new book textbook which is a
pan Yenta encyclopedia of an ordinary
life she wrote it's not a prequel or a
sequel hopefully it's an equal the book
comes out next Tuesday and she's hosting
another gathering at the bean on eight
nine sixteen and if you live near
Chicago you should really stop by you
can find out more by watching this video
or there is a link in the doobly-doo
below but it's gonna be special and
fascinating and generous like everything
Amy does although even if you don't live
in Chicago I hope you'll join me in
reading textbook there are links to get
it in the doobly-doo I think I think we
all have people in our lives whose
generosity has lifted us up or helped
hold us together and I guess I've just
been thinking a lot about those people
in the context of your big news Hank
nerdfighters I'd love to hear about who
those people have been in your lives and
comments I know it's easy to forget him
in the torrent of bad news that we are
here for each other and lucky to have
each other but we are so Thank You Hank
I will actually see you tomorrow because
it will be Esther day speaking of which
I love you